herzlich willkommen zur web video von
den sk heute
ich weiß ich werde ein bisschen was
erzählen über meine musik über die musik
die mir gefällt
und das werde ich immer von diesem
kleinen tapfer machen ja und das nur
weil spotify playlist durchgehen und ich
haben uns erzählen was ich war auch
nicht feuer und wie ich war so besoffen
nicht dann rückwärts vorwärts
hier weist so an oberste stelle ich hier
tolles menrad was ihr das kennt man ja
auch kommentare ein tolles motiv kann
ich bin nie so sicher ob das jetzt
irgendwie besonders bekannte nicht ab
ich glaube ich einer besonders bekannte
künstler ist oder tendenziell eher
unbekannter mann einerseits auf youtube
blogs so 26 millionen klicks
andererseits hat er ja wirklich so viele
videos die irgendwann sind auf jeden
fall ja weil mein lieblingssong auf dem
display treiber der ist richtig geil den
habe ich auch mal nachgesungen neben dem
video glaube ich habe erkennst du dir
internationale ich kenne nicht von max
also nicht von carl krafft das falsch
schwarze hatten nichts zu hören
da bat den ganzen tag ja da hier war die
workout playlist richtig fett da ist
einiges zeug doch was ich tue feiern wie
salzburg war das weil ich beim pumpen
meine ich am partnerstand man ein
bisschen action gebe übrigens finden
studio ich bin jetzt seit zweieinhalb
bis drei jahren im studio ich möchte
mich auch ein brems street entfernt ich
werde ja wieder mit action ja das
natürlich auch geil aber sex tourist
information und wird ja von ungespült
max gädheim slawischer max geht mit mit
raul also mit texten scheinbar bald
wieder punkten
decker information damit er
mit dem aufkommen der muskeln investor
bester fall auch denn sein leben und ich
mal ein bisschen zu klotzig der name was
noch kommt zu einem guten ende
da ich nach unten gehen jetzt würde ich
da hin
der weiße der denkt ich würde wird alle
musik von ihm aus stimmt nicht alle
musik von mir ich höre auf meinen arsch
15 touristen dieses video ist ihm egal
für sie trotzdem schreibt mal die
kommentare wenn charakter seiner
unterhose essen soll bei etwa 2 3 knapp
20 kommentare es ist hinter sich halten
wollen nicht bei 509 mal 400 leute leute
heute bei 500 likes ist krankhaft als
eine unterhose mit videobeweisen stück
ein stück mit ihren unterhosen mit also
wenn ihr das leben weil die käufer für
seine unterhose ist dann jetzt den like
-button drücken
und glaub mir level von likes zusammen
kriegen dann peitsche hinaus keine
ahnung ich schlage zusammen mit seiner
unterhose ist ihr wisst so jetzt kommen
wir zurück zum thema hier ganz oben der
playlist drei kollaps von eminem
richtiges brett richtig richtiges brett
das ist perfekt wenn ihr so eine stunde
lang schon beim sportwart und richtig
anmarsch sein und dann kommt dieses lied
prozent durch gesperrt und gestreikt ja
und ich treffe die musik so gut dass
youtube mit strike dafür hab' dann kommt
dieses lied und hat davon noch mal
richtig power nummer gas geben
und ja wobei tilak plätzen nichts ist
und neu anfangen könnte bisher sollte
man schon recht ich am schluss die
chance hat und dann noch ein bisschen
ganz glauben kann
hier ist throne von kanye west klassiker
der nächste ressort von dr dre auch
richtig fährt das feiere ich generell
hip hop und whirlpools bei hiphop sind
was ihr noch wahrscheinlich noch nicht
wisst was auch sonst
weißwasser max die ich dir so ein
bisschen nebenbei ich hab schon auf ein
paar partys aufgelegt und jetzt ist
kloster von menschen für euch
hauptsächlich hip hop als wenn ich
selbst auflegen richtig heiß also ich
hab mit traktor pro 2 passiert kann
schreibt in die kommentare
gfk hast du erst gekauft ja ich hab ich
junge der premiere auch gedacht schon
der denk ich kaufe in der software nicht
keiner weise erscheint die frage kaufte
die daten kauft ja was haben wir noch
das erste liebe die sind immer diese
fragen aus dem off ist eine elementare
die wir schon vor dem ende in den
britischen frühjahr ich an die box
richtig viel aus cool also eine maschine
meine fresse mit babysprache es nicht
angehen natürlich ist deutsch
ich habe zum beispiel aus kuba wie sagt
next episode one that you feiert das ist
schon was man musik war sexy pumps
anfreunden konnte das machen oder mit
einem freund wenn ihr mir nicht sagte ja
ansonsten generell 15 vielen lebens- und
ja also aus gehört und von neuheit auch
ein bisschen was aber eher selten
ja was ich feiern auf dem handy braucht
weil das das handy von max und was
keiner da ist rick ross habe ich jetzt
entdeckt richtiger mann gary gross ist
richtig wild und mit titeln als kitty
kat war also deppendorf auch bei uns so
wie machen wir weiter
jetzt erst mal 20.000 alben von prinz pi
kauft sehr großer noch sehr gut dauern
aber ich muss sagen das kompass
obwohl es musikalisch ein richtiges
brett ist es gar nicht so oft angehört
habe weil es so ein krasses dpa um ist
das zieht nicht und wissen runter und
also ich muß ich gebe ich mir nicht so
gerne
es geht weiter mit er also gehörlos bot
beim des promipaares zeit prophezeit
schaut der maut es geht weiter mit er
jack dimap geht mir auf youtube ein adr
diesen ultradrive als ihr die man nicht
kennt check dimap die feierlich zur
hölle
die soll nicht so fern das heißt ihr
könnt auch ein bisschen hipster sein
wenn die wird und ja ultra dass ich
wirklich drauf oder wenig sinn macht
dann hätte ich ja also r und oben
eingeben eso l cla dessen beides richtig
geile künstler geben so eine hip hop
richtung checks auf jeden fall weiter
mit martin jondo schilliger typ perfekt
macht gute stimmung
massimo tor ihr wisst weil sie mutter zu
allem hören zum chillen zum ausrasten zu
putten sogar auch fritz kalkbrenner paul
kalkbrenner beste leben passenger der
feier auch habe ich auch angehört ist
gute musik aber tiger ist so
deprimierend die gebe ich mich und yo-yo
jack jones und westermann leiter begriff
von jack johnson krieg ist ein herzchen
feiert auf jeden fall
und ja gewiss khalifa coach babbel in
guckt jetzt immer noch nicht die musik
nicht gefunden habt gebt mal in youtube
um ein usk liefert also ckt sehr geil
dennoch sie oben ihr kennt vielleicht
von programms die zigaretten weg in xxl
sehr geil und wir machen auf zwei
künstler dann macht mich fertig machen
wir schluss dann falls euch gefahren und
lassen sagt lasten
wenn ihr mehr über mein leben erfahren
wollte nie live sehen wollt wo ich
bisschen wasserzähler wenn man
neben so noch was ich fahre was ich
alles was ich tun schreibt kommentare
und ja hier die letzten beiden die ich
gebe es sind bis zum 3 green day ist ein
wenig rock bisher genommen also green
day feierlich sehr geile sache ja okay
ich habe auch von zeit zu zeit in das
jetzt eigentlich weniger aber trotzdem
gehalt und die first century breakdown
beste leben sechs ab und vorletzter ist
ein mac miller richtiger war wo gefällt
mir sehr gut
einerseits richtig chillige mucke
andererseits auch schon relativ die also
hat auch schon inhalt am start der junge
und zum abschluss des paters schreibt
mal die kommentare weiters kennt wenn
jetzt bis jetzt seien und blieben sein
dass mich das wissen weil ich kann also
ich kann doch nicht wirklich abschätzen
wie film der typ ist als partners ist
ein kleiner urahn sind aber einfach gute
musik bei den ganzen leuten diesem 1
die komischen der vorbeter kennen
abstimmt vorbild er verlässt das kennt
ihr facebook pubertät und lass mich
wissen ob airlines bieten sagt mir was
ihr vor einer musik haltet schreibt auch
in die kommentare was für gute musik
hört damit ich meine playlist vielleicht
ein bisschen erweitern kann
und beim abbau und